-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody!
We are here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ready to make you laugh!
Thank you for watching.
Thank you for being here,
everybody.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys,
Thanksgiving is behind us,
but today was another
very big day.
-It's Cyber Monday, guys.
-It is Cyber Monday.
-Record Cyber Monday sales.
-Cyber Monday is on track
to be the biggest
online sales day in history,
with shoppers shelling out
up to $12.7 billion today.
-Yep, today, Americans spent
billions shopping online,
or as that's known in 2020,
every day.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, the whole year
has been Cyber Monday.
At this point, all UPS guys are
built like Dwayne Johnson.
"Where do you want this couch?"
[ Laughter ]
There's deals on everything.
There's nose-hair trimmers,
scuba equipment, lingerie,
and, right now,
there's an Amazon worker loading
them all into the same box,
going, "What is your life?"
[ Laughter ]
I saw that the jewelry store
Jared was offering
up to 50% off storewide.
Though it's kind of weird
telling your girlfriend,
"He went to Jared --
on Cyber Monday."
[ Laughter ]
Some political news.
On Sunday morning,
President Trump did his first
post-election TV interview
with Maria Bartiromo
on Fox News.
It lasted 46 minutes,
and I'm getting the sense
he's not quite over
the election.
Listen to this.
-Mr. President, thank you
very much for being here.
[ Laughter ]
-Even the biggest Trump
supporters were like,
"Maybe we should let
Rudy Giuliani
talk about this instead.
He's been handling this
pretty well."
[ Imitating droplets splashing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Hey.
-It started
as a conspiracy theory
about election fraud
and turned into a commercial
for the Squatty Potty.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I was worried that the end
of Trump's presidency
might get embarrassing,
but at least he's
only on national TV saying,
"Big massive dumps."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
at the White House today,
Melania Trump
unveiled the Christmas --
the official
Christmas decorations.
Take a look.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Why do they keep putting
Melania in charge of the
Christmas decorations?
We know
she doesn't like doing it.
Do you want to hear
the leaked audio again?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Don't put Melania in charge
if she doesn't want to do it!
[ Applause ]
Make it fun!
Put Rudy Giuliani
in charge of this.
He'll have a Santa leaking
eggnog from his side burns.
[ Laughter ]
Put Jared Kushner on the shelf,
change his position every day.
[ Laughter ]
Melania made him have
two middle fingers.
Have Mike Pence do it.
He's so white,
he's just a top hat and a pipe
away from being the new Frosty.
[ Laughter ]
But this year's gingerbread
White House is incredible.
It features more than
400 pounds of dough
and a gingerbread man
who refuses to leave.
[ Laughter ]
Trump must love the decorations,
because he's used a tiny
gingerbread Oval Office desk
in his last press conference.
[ Laughter ]
Did you see that?
What is he doing?
Is that a desk?
Or is that the tiny table
that separates the pizza
from the box?
[ Laughter ]
And here's some news
about the President-elect.
Over the weekend,
Joe Biden ran into
a little trouble
while playing with his dog.
Listen to this.
-The President-elect,
he spent Sunday night
at the doctor's office
after twisting his ankle
playing with his dog.
Biden's doctor says,
after a CT scan,
he ended up with hairline
fractures in his right foot.
He'll probably have to be
in a boot for a little while.
-Biden was like,
"Ah, it's no big deal.
I've been dealing with a
fractured hairline for years."
[ Laughter ]
When the news broke,
Kamala Harris was stretching
in the bullpen like,
"I guess I'm getting in the game
sooner than I thought."
[ Laughter ]
"Ooh! Let's go."
I feel bad for Biden, though.
Nobody wants to start a new job
in a walking boot.
It's hard to act tough
with China when you have to
leave a press conference
on one of those knee scooters.
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell ringing ]
I couldn't -- I don't know how
to make the space work work.
You know, those things.
[ Bell ringing ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Bell ringing continues ]
No, okay.
Hey, here's a big -- a big sp--
Here's a burg?
Here's a burg.
Here's a burger for you.
Who else wants a burger?
-A burger, I want a burger.
-Anybody else want a burger?
-Give me a burger.
-Burger, burger, burger, burger,
burger, burger, no problem.
Oh, here's a big sports story
for you here.
[ Laughter ]
You love sports,
don't you, Tariq?
-Uh, pretty much no.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, here's one for you.
The Denver Broncos had to face
the New Orleans Saints without
any of their quarterbacks.
Watch this.
-In Denver, practice squad
receiver Kendall Hinton
got the start for the Broncos
after all of the team's
quarterbacks
were disqualified
over coronavirus concerns.
-The Broncos lost, 31-3.
Hinton completed
just one pass, overall.
-Oh, man.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the NFL saw the Oscars
go without a host and said,
"We can top that."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the Broncos played without
a quarterback and lost, 31-3.
Even more upsetting, the Jets
had their starting quarterback
and still lost just as bad.
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
Tecate beer,
which is made in Holland --
Did you know that?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It is made in Holland,
so it's now facing a lawsuit
for posing as a Mexican beer.
Tough year
for fans of Mexican beer.
You got fake Tecate
or you got Corona.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
I saw that Netflix
is being pressured
by the British government
to put a disclaimer
on "The Crown,"
saying that it's fictional.
Yeah.
They also want everyone to know
that Helena Bonham Carter
is not actually
the Queen's sister.
She's an actress.
And also, you see those credits
you see rolling at the end?
Doesn't happen in real life.
[ Laughter ]
It's what they call a TV show.
I don't know
what to make of this.
In a new interview,
George Clooney revealed
some interesting information
about how he cuts his hair.
Watch this.
-I've been cutting my own hair
for 25 years.
So, years ago, I bought a --
a thing called a Flowbee.
It comes with a vacuum cleaner
and the clippers?
-Yes!
-Yeah. I still have it.
My haircuts
take literally two minutes.
I go --
-Is this -- Is this Flowbee?
-Yeah, it's Flowbee.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-No.
-If you think that's crazy,
I heard he manscapes
with a Slap Chop.
[ Laughter ]
That's what I heard.
And, finally, I saw that Oreo
is now selling
a cookie-scented candle
on their Website.
I'm already excited
for tomorrow's headline --
"Florida man rushed to ER
after eating lit candle."
Happy Thanksgiving.
I hope everybody
had a nice Thanksgiving.
Did you -- Did you --
Did you spatchcock?
-I did.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-How did it turn out?
-Best turkey
I've ever made, man.
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
-I mean, yeah.
-Because you've talked
the talk before.
-I have,
but I walk the walk, as well.
-Yeah, but usually
you spatchcock
and then
you throw it on the grill.
-Yeah, but -- Yeah,
I didn't grill this time.
Well, I spatchcocked it,
I put it on the grill,
but just the oven grill.
Like not outside, like on the --
-Yeah, on the barbecue grill.
-Yeah, no.
-But is it better than that,
even?
-Better.
Better than anything ever.
-Spatchcock is the --
You butterfly the turkey.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you take the backbone.
-I just told you that
Thursday, right?
-No, last year, you told me.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, I mean --
Whatever.
I don't really
pay attention to you.
[ Laughter ]
When -- When --
The night I texted --
My assistant reads me the texts
that you send.
[ Laughter ]
No, you told me
you were the doing that,
but I was like,
"Oh, did you really do it?"
You went for it.
-Yeah. It was awesome.
-Yeah. It was a -- it was a fun
Thanksgiving, I think, for us.
I mean, we got invited to do the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade.
We got invited to -- oh.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Which is an honor just to even
be invited there.
But then we got asked to open
the Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade,
which is unbelievable.
We were so excited about that.
We got -- I got here around
6:40, 6:30, something like that.
And it was
raining cats and dogs.
I go, "Oh, man."
Already, the idea of pulling off
a parade is tough.
But to do it during a rain
is just gonna be insane.
But we got there.
They did a great job --
NBC, also New York City
did a great job.
Thank you, Bill de Blasio,
for even letting it happen
and do it.
It made a lot of people happy.
So, we were in the Macy's --
Actually in the department store
for the first time.
-Yeah.
-That was our holding --
-That was our dressing room.
-It was so bizarre.
Our dressing room was in Macy's.
It was all dolled up for
Christmas and all that stuff.
And we were practicing
the dancing.
It was like, "Oh, my gosh."
And we got to perform live,
which we never get to do.
-Yeah.
-Because if you're on the float,
there's no way you can
mic those things,
so you have to, like,
lip-sync to a track.
Which sometimes works
and sometimes doesn't.
There was one year,
it was so cold,
I couldn't even move my lips.
-Yeah, wow.
-It was like -- yeah.
But it was wild.
And again, I want to thank our
choreographer, Sarah O'Gleby,
who always is just --
[ Cheers and applause ]
She is so talented.
And made it so fun.
I love that.
It was -- It was definitely
a memorable Thanksgiving.
But happy we got to do that
and make a lot of people laugh
and smile.
But another thing happened
on Thanksgiving --
the dog show,
the national dog show.
-Mm.
-Yeah. You watch that?
-Of course.
-Yeah, of course.
There was
a very interesting dog there.
Check this out.
-Here's the Miniature
American Shepherd.
This dog is named
Love that Jimmy Fallon.
Said they named him Jimmy
because of his high energy
and goofy personality.
There you go, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. What?
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's real?
-That's real.
-What's up with --
-"Love that Jimmy Fallon"
was the name of that dog.
-Yeah, man, he's got
a goofy personality, so...
[ Laughter ]
What else you gonna call him?
-Yeah, well --
No, I mean -- Well, he's a
Miniature American Shepherd,
from Denton, Texas,
which is outside of Dallas.
But I was looking at the dog.
You know,
'cause I watch these things,
and honestly,
a flawless physical specimen...
[ Laughter ]
...of an animal.
The judges loved him.
[ Laughter ]
They were in awe of him,
I think.
And, you know, more importantly,
they respected him...
[ Laughter ]
...is what --
That's what I took --
That's what I took away
from watching
Love that Jimmy Fallon
on the dog show.
I don't know.
Let's see how he did.
-The Miniature
American Shepherd --
there's your winner
of the herding group.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The winner!
Yeah, so I open the Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade,
and I won the dog show, so...
-You got Best in Show.
-I had the best Thanksgiving
I ever had.
Yeah, it was awesome.